[Music]
welcome to this session about Quantum
Computing for Enterprise developers so
this session is a
related to the book Quantum Computing
for developers from running you can also
see my name and my Twitter handle and
with that I think let's start the
presentation I'm a Java developer a Java
champion and a Java one Rockstar
I'm active in the Java development
Community I'm the colleague of open gfx
where we created javafx specifications
and implementations and I'm the lead for
the open GDK mobile project
and I'm also the um co-author of the
definitive guide to Modern Java clients
with Java FX which is a book about uh
they have on the client and I'm the uh
as you could see the author of The
quantum Computing for Java developers
book I was part of the original team
that boarded uh Java to Linux in 1996 uh
and so so I've been around
quite a long time in the Java world
okay
um I think it's about time for um some
code now so we will use a strange
simulator and we will write some code in
Java at using the high level API without
using a Quantum instructions uh yet so
um what will we do we will create a
project I'm going to use netbeans
and I will create a project that creates
that generates a random number well
actually a random bit is going to be
it's going to generate zero one and then
I'll create a few other projects as well
so let me switch
to netbeans
and
um
I prepared the um the code but
um I think it's um
probably more fun if I remove what I've
already had
but I'll just put it in comments just in
case
just in case I forgot what to do so
um first of all we will create a um
uh so we have a Java application with a
main method and we will
[Music]
um
color method
Generate random bits
um which
um will well let's say we'll we'll just
uh print a random bit you know what I'm
gonna remove this this I think it should
it should work it's a live demo what can
possibly go on
Generate random bit uh needs to be a
static method
um so the high level API of strange
contains a class which is called classic
it's probably already imported and that
contains a number of classical
algorithms one of those is random bit
and it returns an end so that sounds
very easy
so we just invoke that method and we
will get a random bit and to make sure
that uh
this is a random bit let's print it out
our random bit is
so don't worry this is a
[Music]
we will later discuss what the
classic.random bit is doing but at this
moment I just want to show how you can
use quantum
benefits without having to use the code
that without having to go deep in the
code that's doing this
well while we're actually here I'll
quickly show the classic class and you
see in the the random bits
implementation you see that this is
dealing with qubits and so we'll come
back to that later this is going to be
executed on on a Quantum simulator uh
a simple Quantum execution environment
but forget about that for now just see
that we have this method that generates
mprints a random bit
so if we run the
application
compile and run sorry you will see that
our random bit here is uh zero
how do we know that this is a random bit
well we don't so we just run the
application again
and now the random bit is again zero
and we run it again
and now it is
ah
again zero
um
this is totally random otherwise I would
have made it one for the third time to
show that it's more or less random
and now
oh yeah here we are now it is a one so
this time uh it's a one so we had three
times zero and one time one so this is
not yet of course a statistical proof
that
um this is a really a random number
generated but you could see that at
least a number of times it's uh it was
generating zero and one time it was
generating one
to um
we can actually count the zeros and ones
so for example we will use 0 and 1 as a
counters and we can iterate for example
uh
thousand times over this
random bit generator
and when the random bit is uh
zero
we will
increment the zero
and when the random bit is one
we will increment the one and in the end
we will just print uh um the number of
zeros and ones
um
what's zero zero
and
for
40 times
and one for
one
time
what did I do wrong
brackets
where did I ah forgot the plus here okay
we saved this and we run this again
um oh I I was running from a netbeans
now but I can also run uh from maven
just to um to demonstrate that you can
use this from any IDE or from
any command line application so this was
called random so if we compile and then
exec Java
I think this should work
okay yeah there we there you go you see
our random bit uh it's a it's a bit
small but it shows our random bit was
Zero for 514 times and one for 486 times
so
um that being a bit small I'll um
run it again
with uh netbeans because that allows me
to to use the slightly bigger font size
here okay now it was 482 times 0 and 518
times 1.
so
um that's
um granted not very impressive
um for a Quantum algorithm that's even
hidden behind the um
behind the classic interface but it is
the the very first algorithm that I
wanted to show and it's a
I think the outcome is very
understandable
and it is also extremely relevant the
moment that you can generate zero or one
in a truly random way you can generate a
seat in a random way and then you can
generate the whole numbers uh the number
generator in a random way
so that's a very uh useful start so that
is that that was the the easiest
algorithm generating a random bit let's
make it a bit more exciting now and
let's talk about the search uh
capabilities of a Quantum algorithm
there's an algorithm called Grover's
algorithm well-known Quantum algorithm
that allows to search in an um in the
list and if you're given sort of a
function which is called an oracle
um
that algorithm Grover's algorithm will
determine the
um the element from the list
for which the function would return one
in square root of n steps where n is the
number of uh
elements in the list typically it would
it it would take n steps to be
guaranteed that you have the correct
element but it's if with a Quantum
algorithm it will be square root of n
I'm not going into detail about why that
is there that is covered in my book in
the the first chapters the most
important part is that we somehow
believe that this is a Quantum algorithm
that's much faster if executed on a real
quantum computer
then uh on the uh then then it can
possibly be implemented on a classical
computer the important part for us now
is that can we use this in Java
so let's create a um a second
application that does this uh search uh
I'm gonna put this in comment
and I'll use a search okay so the search
I removed that
um
oh yeah and
um shouldn't make those methods public
and I should use the proper indentation
and so but um
I think you got a point
so let's make it very simple we are
going to search in a list of strings and
we will have we will use colors and we
will use a
four colors with green
uh
blue
and yellow for example so this is the
list of items that we are going to
search for and then we have a c a
function and this is a bit a strange
concept
for many developers who encounter this
at first but we should
um
conceptually think that we do not know
the function so I will have to type the
function now but
um you you should consider it as someone
is giving us this function and we don't
know what it is or what it is doing and
we need to know what it is going to uh
return uh no we do not need to know what
this function is going to return for
everything we just need to know
for what value of the colors is this
function going to return one
and um well because I'm cheating here
because I happen to be the one who
creates the function as well but that
should be a different role when the
color color equals uh for example let's
say green then we are going to return
one and otherwise we are going to return
zero and
I forgot the silicone
okay
so that is that is that is our function
and suppose that we don't know this
function so that this is blurt or this
is a random then we would have to
execute this function four times to see
is this function returning the green
color or not so we would have to do it
four times
with in Quantum Computing we can do this
in two steps with the algorithm and it's
called
um search so the classic.search requires
a list what are the possible uh what is
what are the list of elements what is
the list of elements that we want to
search for and what function do we want
to use for searching
one of the reasons that I'm giving this
example is that it shows how the the the
Java function
operators are really applicable to
Quantum Computing algorithms already so
that you can take advantage of or both
Java and the quantum Computing here
um the result of this um
I okay yeah so it's it's returning uh uh
the the type of the uh elements in the
list so
the result of this classic search should
be
um the well the element in the list that
matches what the function is returning
value one one four and to make sure that
this works is um
let's print it out so it's list and got
um
found
okay do I have everything yep okay then
we can run this
compiling one
and this is a going to
um
invoke the algorithm
and it will also print how many steps
the algorithm was using
so
okay steps is
1.57 steps and with a probability of
almost
um one which is 100 percent uh the
algorithm says that uh green is uh the
one so this is uh um
growth uh Source algorithm does not give
100 probability
um it's not 100 accurate but it gives at
the square root of the number uh of
elements it gives uh something with a
very very high uh probability and then
the
in in my book I discussed the
um why that comes
this is um second example classic uh
reports to search
the third algorithm and that that is
something that's often very interesting
to um journalists and to more people
talking about quantum computer the third
algorithm is about integer factorization
if you know the hype about one of the
hype about Quantum Computing is that
this will break encryption and that is
because a quantum computer is supposed
to be able to easily factor a large
number into its uh factors for example
15 equals 5 times 3 you really need to
take that with a serious grain of salt
while the algorithm is indeed capable of
doing that we are
far away from
quantum computers that are powerful and
reliable enough to do this in a reliable
way so I I try not to over hype this but
it is really something important and it
is also something that's very tangible
to um to many people and that might help
convincing people why they need to look
into Quantum Computing even if this is
not something that's going to
um hack your bank account tomorrow it is
something that you should be aware of
and especially the mechanism behind this
so how do we do this well actually this
is uh using the the high level API of
strange also very simple we can just ask
um to factor a number
and uh
what this algorithm Q factor is going uh
to do is it will search for factors of
15 that are not 1 or 15
so
we then know that if we have one factor
that we um
can Factor it
um
15 into
Factor
and
and then at 15 divided by the uh
vector and then of course the uh order
Factor
okay I think that should beat I noticed
that sometimes
um
running it from the IDE
becomes slower
and this is definitely something
um it's important to mention this is
um something that uh
slow
on the quantum simulator because it uses
lots of memory on a Quantum simulator
this is much slower than on a classical
computer okay so this was fast because
it it yeah it had a good random number
from the beginning but a Quantum
simulator simulates all the possible
states of a real quantum computer and
that's a huge number of states
and it simulates this in classical
Hardware so it is actually
um extremely
non-performant compared to a real
quantum computer so in the uh scale you
would have a Quantum simulator is
slowest than a classical computer is
faster but then the Quant the real
quantum computer is is fastest of well
of course only for
some certain algorithms okay so what we
did now was we had three applications uh
generating a random bit using search
and factoring an integer into uh two
numbers